welcome to the ten thousand year mystery
my series of oil paintings about a
marking system for communication over a
ten thousand year time span
here's some background for the paintings
we need a marking system to warn future
generations about the long-term danger
of nuclear waste storage sites
like this one in new mexico
think of science fiction novels that
take place in the far
future when people are trying to make
sense
of our civilization's artifacts
one challenge of long-term communication
is the drift of meaning
both linguistic and symbolic
axial procession another change over
time
will be the position of stars in a 26
000 year cycle
this is a good language-free way for us
to communicate about the passage of
millennia
here's an example on the left of the
stars in new mexico
is seen now in the year 2000 on the
right are the stars as they will appear
there in year four faster
the difference shows the passage of time
over just two thousand years
i make sky map stencils by punching
guide holes then i use those to
accurately mark
the star positions on the canvas
this painting is called we left
part of the warning text reads the waste
from nuclear weapons we made
the weapons are gone but the danger
endures
transferring maps on the canvas has been
a challenge
here i take the clear plastic film over
a reverse printed topographic map
i applied oil paint to the contour lines
of the map
and then flipped it over onto the canvas
making an accurate print of the
topographic map
that's those blobby rainbow lines and
the green dots will feel the centers are
the stars
the weapons are gone but the danger
endures
we left this message here for you we
left this here for you
we left
mule deer this painting combines an
aerial view mineral map
with a horizon viewed sky map
i used a technique called gridding up to
transfer the map shapes to the canvas
i numbered the squares on the map and on
the canvas
then referred to the map as i painted in
the shapes square by square
the deer's hook prints mark the star
locations
just as deer leak tracks and trails
civilizations leave tracks and trails
for the far
future
i assigned the false colors to the
mineral map
in such a way that it also functions as
a traditional
vertical landscape view with the deer
looking out at us
desert raving this is a map of magnetic
anomalies of the earth
some bird species use these magnetic
fields for navigation
the bumpy warning text on the left is
buried under the matte paint
as you can see on the right giving a
sense of physical degradation of a
warning message over time
the raven shape reminds me of a warplane
the new mexico site is for the waste for
nuclear weapons
research and production
oracle bone chinese i really want to do
some paintings with this
i've translated the nuclear waste
warning message into this 3600 year old
language
it's another way to convey linguistic
drift over time
10 000 years in the past was the dawn of
agriculture
so long-term future thinking can be
mind-boggling
but as you've just seen long-term
thinking can also be enjoyable
i'd like to thank the long nap
foundation and ignite
for giving us the forum in which to do
that thinking
and i'd like to thank you all for being
here this evening